today we are doing a Mac Pro upgrade and
this is something that really to be
completely honest with you my Mac Pro
doesn't really need this upgrade but
since I can do it I'm going to one of
the highlights of the Mac Pro originally
was this is something that is built for
the future there's so many different
things that you can install to upgrade
this computer but it's a little bit
overwhelming so we're gonna start very
simply with 1.5 terabytes of RAM and a
new 8 terabyte solid-state raid drive in
addition to some internal upgrades we
also have the Mac Pro wheels I know a
lot of you guys we're making fun of me
and people who buy these on Twitter but
I really wanted to check them out and I
thought that these wheels really needed
a proper review also that Mac Pro is
heavy we do move it around a lot in the
studio especially for shoots like this
so if I'm able to wheel that thing from
my office into here I don't know I think
it's worth the $800 so huge thank you to
OD UC mac sales.com is a website that
i've actually been using since I was too
young to even order things on the
internet I'm just thinking of childhood
Justine right now because I used to ask
for RAM and hard drive upgrades for like
my birthday and Christmas and this is
where my dad used to get it from so it's
kind of crazy that this is all coming
around full circle adult Justine is also
very excited I'll put a link in the
description if you want to check out Oh
W see they have so many different
upgrades they also have this incredible
8 terabytes solid-state drive that I've
been using for editing everything
recently the best part about it is going
through them you're going to be saving
so much money on different upgrades like
RAM and drives as opposed to going
directly through Apple's I ran out of
space when I was editing the 8k Mac Pro
unboxing so Jonathan actually told me
about this Thunder blade drive and it
has completely changed everything they
have a bunch of different sizes so I
will also put that in the description as
well this is the Excelsior 4m 2 8
terabyte solid-state drive and I just
looked on their website they have one of
these that goes up to 16 terabytes this
looks like something that I get my sushi
in but there's one point 5 terabytes of
RAM oh my gosh this is beautiful before
we start upgrading let's open these
wheels this is heavy this is very
very heavy I don't know on my scale over
here actually I do
let's weigh it I'm gonna say at least
eight and a half pounds well clearly I'm
a really bad judge of weight it's 5.3
it's heavy it's heavy it feels heavy
[Music]
Wow look how cool that looks here's our
tool for installation guess we'll find
out so these are not normal caster
wheels this is industrial designed
perfection and I'm not just saying that
because I'm an Apple sheep these are
beautiful
[Music]
that is a smooth ride can't wait to
install these this is gonna be great
looks like we've got everything ready
time for the upgrade upgrading the Mac
Pro was even easier than I originally
thought
all I had to do was unscrew these screws
remove the faceplate and pop in our
drive replace the screws and the
faceplate and that was it and moving on
to 1.5 terabytes of RAM these faceplates
popped right off giving you access to
add or remove RAM and in this case we
are adding all 1.5 terabytes
mac pro can use either our dim or lrdimm
but they can't be combined so lrdimm
modules must be all of the same size
it's also worth noting that only the 24
core and 28 core Mac Pro's to have the
ability to be expanded to 1.5 terabytes
I'm also officially available for hire
to edit and do any special effects for
the next Star Wars movie I'm here just
tweet me got the solid-state drives
installed got the RAM installed and I
was just about to install the wheels
I've got my little bit that they
included and I'm reading the directions
and I get to number 8 it says use a
flexible screw driver with this bit it
comes with the wheels guess what I don't
have guess what I didn't even know was
something that existed so now I need to
find a flexible screw driver or some
other solution to try to get these legs
off and I will continue this video so
Home Depot has curbside pickup so I
basically just have to drive up call
them
my screwdriver that's good there's so
many mean they're like probably really
long it's a weekend everybody must need
a flexible screwdriver
so now that we have the tool that we
need to install the wheels it's really
really simple I have my directions over
here and basically there is a screw that
is inside of these legs unscrew it pop
off the legs and put on the wheels this
is like this is super flexible I hope
this works because I don't even know
okay we're in we're in is what it's
working there's two little prongs that
help you guide this into the end here
you put those two little pins into the
slots and we're off to the races
[Music]
I feel like I want an episode of home
improvement
I feel like MacGyver I feel like the
property brothers just finished building
their latest house and doing some
interior decorating a lot of the Stewart
not in jail I'm out of examples of who I
could possibly be we have three more to
go
[Music]
that's it
yes that's done now I'm gonna lift it up
put that top on take it for a spin
[Music]
look at that beauty turn my whole life
has brought me to this point right now
and I could not be happier
[Music]
now we roll this thing in style to my
office all right Little Mac let's let's
go this is so worth it back to your home
I don't want to talk about my cable
management it's really not good but I'll
work on it later let's plug this guy
back in and check out our upgrades
everything is set up I would say if this
is the first time that I'm booting this
up but since I had a day between
shooting this video I did actually
already boot this up and verify that
everything works properly if you guys
can see here we have the 1.5 terabytes
of memory all twelve spots you guys can
see here this is where we popped in the
solid-state drive so this here is the
software that these drives use it's
called soft raid these are the two
drives that I have this is the one that
we just installed there are no errors
you can also go here and you can set it
to be optimized for workstation server
digital video digital audio or
photography and my post mates has just
arrived which is really great news but
inside of here if one of your drives
does fail this will hopefully allow you
to not lose any data at all I do need to
figure this out because it says that
there is an i/o error on one of my
drives so go in here and all of this
stuff copied very quickly this is all
the stuff that I shot over the past
couple of days we've got our iPhone SE
video we've got the Mac Pro upgrade
which you're watching now normally I
only edit off of an external drive but
since I've been home a lot more I have
completely filled up all over the space
on my computer so being able to have
this 8 terabyte internal is gonna make a
huge difference what I usually do is
I'll edit off of either an external
drive or on the computer and then I save
all of my files to the jelly-fish server
what's great Bill about the jelly-fish
server is when I would have multiple
people working on a project we would be
able to work directly off of the server
but since I've just been born in the
house and in the house board and working
alone we figured out a really great way
to do remote work use
this app called post-lab i'm gonna be
making a full video about that if you
haven't seen it already but it's been
incredible because I've been able to
edit with Jenna and Tyler and we can be
working off of the same Final Cut
library so if you are doing remote work
and looking for a Final Cut solution
this is amazing and you have to check it
out but in the meantime I'm incredibly
happy with my upgrades I know that this
is definitely something that for what
I'm usually editing it's definitely
overkill I am well aware of that but man
this is gonna make 8k editing so
seamless so now that means maybe camera
grade is an order
[Music]